he asked me to dance he is the most
hideous dancer I've ever seen in my life
I mean it was horrible and this guy was
sweating all over me like his sweat was
like it was raining basically everywhere
and I was just like what grossed out
from it but I knew I had to keep him
happy because that's what Jeffrey and
Gulen would expect from me a graphic
account of a first encounter
Prince Andrew claims didn't happen
Virginia Roberts alleges that age 17 she
was trafficked to London by the
convicted sex offender Jeffrey Epstein
and that that night shortly after this
picture was taken she had sex with
Prince Andrew now aged 35 and called
Virginia gue Frey she's reiterated her
allegation in her first UK interview and
she had a message for the UK public I
implore the people in the UK to stand up
beside me to help me fight this fight to
not accept this as being okay this is
not some sorted sex story this is a
story of being trafficked
Prince Andrew has admitted being friends
with Jeffrey Epstein and even visited
him after his conviction for child sex
offences an attempt last month to tell
his side of the story in a Newsnight
interview backfired amidst the backlash
he was forced to step back from royal
duties since then he's kept a low
profile but he did categorically deny
miss goof Ray's allegations insisting he
has no recollection of meeting her and
maintaining her version of events could
not have happened I had suffered what I
would describe as an overdose of
adrenaline in the Falklands War when I
was shot at and I simply it was it was
it was almost impossible for me to sweat
Jeffrey Epstein suicide in the summer
has heightened calls for those who
surrounded and enabled him to face
justice
Miska Frey argues many of the defenses
given aren't good enough the people on
the inside are going to keep coming up
with these ridiculous excuses like his
arm was elongated or the photo was
doctored or he came to New York to break
up with Jeffrey Epstein I
come on I'm calling BS on this because
that's what it is he knows what happened
I know it happened and there's only one
of us telling the truth and I know
that's me
in a statement Buckingham Palace said it
is emphatically denied that the Duke of
York had any form of sexual contact or
relationship with Virginia Roberts any
claim to the country is false and
without foundation and any suggestion of
impropriety with underage minors is
categorically untrue there are now calls
for the Duke of York to testify under
oath to the FBI while none of these
allegations are new their repetition
will no doubt cause further discomfort
for the palace and for the prince
Helen Ann Smith skinny's